Пыль, грязь, усталость. Будьте готовы ко
всему.
>> 700 км. [музыка]
Все в пыли.
>> Здесь сбываются все ваши страхи.
>> Думал, что может я даже к такому не
готов.
>> Мы были в шоке.
>> У меня, конечно, немного страх был
>> перед лицом [музыка] неизвестности.
>> 24 предпринимателя на больших скоростях
двигаются. Каждый километр, который мы
ехали по этим дорогам на баге,
>> это очень жёстко повлияет на вашу жизнь.
Многое в мире ты мог бы не [музыка]
увидеть.
>> Мы всегда видим только одну сторону
медали.
>> Чувства очень такие завораживающие.
Просто невероятное место к этому всему
прикоснуться. Есть романтика в этом. А в
чём смысл багетуров?
Наше путешествие берёт начало на
территории Западного Казахстана.
прекрасного города Актау, который окутан
волнами Каспийского моря и просторами
Мангастау.
Друзья, сегодня настжим.
>> Первая встреча героев даёт возможность
рассказать о себе, познакомиться с
остальными участниками тура и обдумать,
как извлечь максимум пользы от
предстоящего опыта.
Управление ожиданиями - это не то, что с
вами случится, а то, как вы воспримете
то, что с вами случается. И это
очень-очень важно, потому что когда вы
управляете ожиданиями, вы управляете
своим настроением.
[аплодисменты]
[музыка]
Закат солнца, крайние пейзажи города
перед стартом экспедиции. Какие тайные
красоты покажет нам Устюрт.
[музыка]
Эй, [музыка]
эй,
эй. Выяснилось,
что здесь участники из тринадцати стран
мира. Вы можете представить?
Удивительно, насколько мы собираем
интернационал. Сейчас мы садимся на
наших коней, проведём инструктаж. Наш
приоритет безопасность. Мы как в
авиакомпании.
Приём. Приём. Это Олег.
[музыка]
>> [музыка]
>> Одна из красот, что несёт названиелб.
Живописные холмы из древнемиловой породы
ярких цветов, что даже получило
неофициальное название тирамису.
>> [музыка]
>> Всем привет. На связи Владимир. Сегодня
первый день, и это сегодня уже третье
или четвёртое пробитое колесо. Опасность
заключается в том, что на больш скорости
мы, гружёные проезжаем, где лежат
маленькие опасные камни, и эти камни
поднимаются и под весом втыкаются.
Иногда у нас получается их
отремонтировать, но не всегда. В данном
случае нам придётся сейчас менять
колесо. Самый казус то, что это одна из
машин технического сопровождения. И как
назло, самые важные машины выходят
временно из строя. Все наши гости уехали
далеко вперёд, а машина технического
сопровождения одна из находится с нами,
и мы сейчас помогаем её реанимировать.
[музыка]
Прекраснейший Багитур для того, чтобы
выйти из зоны комфорта.
>> Это мой третий Багитур. Я уже знаю,
насколько это атмосферный, крутой
формат. Мы будем там 5 дней находиться,
спать в палатках. Я посмотрю, насколько
это сможет очистить мои мозги и сделать
ресет.
Мне очень нравится именно этот формат,
потому что это природа, мы без связи. В
основном это бывает у нас мужская
компания, очень всё легко, очень
атмосферно. То есть вот баги формат мне
нравится именно за глубину.
Мне сложно по-русски излагать свои
мысли. Я уже 26 лет живу в Америке,
поэтому давайте я скажу на английском. I
have very low expectations of the store.
I'm excited to meet with other young
entrepreneurs. All about building
longterm meaningful.
Нужно иногда находить те инструменты,
которые дают возможность нам выйти из
своей привычной среды. Да и в классном
окружении, на баге за 4 дня. Я уверен,
что я соберу большую коллекцию инсайтов.
>> Насколько это будет круто, я думаю, эта
неделя покажет.
He.
[музыка]
Сюда присоединился Багитур с Маргулан
Калевичем, чтобы перезагрузиться, чтобы
познакомиться новыми людьми.
>> Да, такой новый для меня формат. Первый
раз я, в принципе, в Казахстане в граф
всегда хотел присоединиться в такие
мероприятия. И Багитур был просто прямо,
кстати, приехал со Штатов только ради
Багитура.
>> Я уже третий раз на Багитуре. Я первый
раз был на Алтае, потом по центральному
Казахстану и сейчас мы на Западе. Каждый
раз мы что-то новое получаем.
>> Баги тур с Маргуланом мне подарила моя
любимая супруга на день рождения.
>> Эти места просто завораживалась своей
красотой. Обычно мы ездим в горы для
того, чтобы там поездить на лыжах, да,
там подышать таким морозным воздухом,
скажем так. А здесь диссонанс.
Испытываешь дессонанс, потому что жара
40°. И я так понимаю, что мы ездим по
дну моря. Это очень красиво. [музыка]
Я, конечно, не ожидал никакого комфорта.
Это дикая природа. В целом, именно баги
туры я представлял себе а ещё хуже, чем
есть. То есть э для меня багитуры, я
думал, что мы здесь вообще будем жить, э
в пыли, есть пыль, мыться пылью. Вот. Но
классно, что этого нет.
>> Это такой мужской тур, который точно
стоит посетить, чтобы и кайфануть,
побывать в Казахстане и пообщаться с
очень интересными людьми, включая,
естественно, Маргуналанала Калиевича.
>> [музыка]
[музыка]
>> когда с тобой в туре находится
мощный предприниматель [музыка] кратно
выше тебя. У тебя в моменте того, когда
ты находишься в пустыне, ты отдыхаешь и
твой мозг выдаёт тебе какие-то вопросы,
и ты хотел бы этими вопросами с кем-то
поделиться и об кого-то удариться. И
Маргулан, конечно, прекраснейший
человек, который очень хорошо и
качественно даёт ответы, так как он сам
пережил и взлёты, и падения, ну, и у
него насмотренность, такое количество
бизнесменов прошло через него. Поэтому
[музыка] ты сразу получаешь ответы на
свои вопросы. Уезжая отсюда, у тебя есть
уже какая-то стратегия.
[музыка]
>> Вот и настал наш второй день в Багетуре.
Хотел бы поделиться своим первым опытом
за 40 лет, можно сказать, спанья в
палатке. Конечно, в моём понимании
палатки должны быть маленькие или
поворотливые, но здесь прямо мегалюкс, я
бы сказал. Вот хотел бы начать с того,
что я очень [музыка] не рекомендую сюда
ехать,
потому что здесь бываются все ваши
страхи. Я очень боялся, что попаду на
разбор к Маргулан Каричу. То есть у меня
я хотел, но, ну, это страшно было
немножко, потому что после этого надо
что-то будет со своей жизнью делать. Это
сразу случилось.
>> Мы делали разбор. Мы увидели, что мы
всегда видим только одну сторону медали.
Лдан Колевище всех нас послушал 25
человек, потом сказал другой ответ, и мы
были в шоке.
>> Я понял, вот вчера проанализировал, что
Маргулан Колич очень многие вещи уже
говорил в книге, на Ютубе, ещё где-то.
Вот. Но ты не придаёшь такую ценность,
когда просто вот YouTube смотришь, то ли
много факторов, ну, которые отвлекают
тебя, а здесь ты сфокусирован, то есть
здесь у тебя окружение. Здесь ты
отключён, нет связи. И вот эта вот
информация, она вообще по-другому
доходит. То ли, может быть, шикарная
степь в Казахстане, не знаю, что так
благоприятное влияет. Возможно, это
много-много факторов, да, которые вот
влияют на это, и это надо
прочувствовать. Сегодня я почти не спал.
До утро переваривало всю эту информацию
интересную. Спалось потрясающе. Первый
раз из степи зарядился. И хочу сегодня
счастливо прожить этот день и совершить
сегодня новый рывок вперёд.
Это это что? Это что творится?
>> Это только у меня или у всех?
>> У всех. У всех.
>> У всех. А вчера кто сказал? Энан
говорит, очень странно, говорит, почему,
говорит, качество резко изменилось, а
цена осталась прежней за Багитур.
Поэтому требуем повышение
[смех]
Багетур с Марголоном Клевичем - это
особенное мероприятие, в котором
соединяются очень много несоединимых
вещей. С одной стороны, это жара, пыль,
грязь, а с другой стороны - это природа.
Видим великолепные, великолепные
пейзажи. И когда мы приезжаем на
Багетур, даже если он не первый, то
всегда уезжаем другими.
>> [музыка]
[музыка]
>> Босжира. связана с древним океаном
Тетис, который миллионы лет назад
покрывал эту территорию. После его
высыхания остались миловые отложения,
которые подверглись эрозии, сформировав
современный ландшафт.
>> Мы находимся на самом красивом месте,
наверное, нашего тура. Это место,
конечно, навивает на разные философские
мысли о смысле, о жизни. И вот я
подумал, а в чём смысл багитуров? Для
меня смысл багитуров в том, чтобы
передать людям, что истинные ценности -
это не про деньги. Истинные ценности -
это прожить счастливую жизнь. У меня,
например, самого миссия прожить
счастливую жизнь, изучая, применяя и
обучая людей эффективным законам жизни.
И вот Багитур чем мне нравится то, что я
с одной стороны проживаю счастливую
жизнь на Багитуре, а с другой стороны
обучаю людей эффективным законам жизни.
И это прямо мне даёт очень сильную
энергию, мотивацию, особенно такие
места, места силы. Вы знаете, [музыка] в
процессе обучения очень важно, чтобы
ученик доверял учителю. И вот очень
важно, чтобы был контекст или фон,
который снимает лишние мысли. И моя
задача выдернуть этих занятых
бизнесменов и инвесторов из привычной
среды, чтобы они оставили всю эту суету
в городе. Здесь надо думать о глубоком,
о сути. того, чем они занимаются, чтобы
они каждый прожил это и каждый
задумался, для чего он живёт и вообще
[музыка] в чём миссия и цель его жизни.
[музыка]
>> [музыка]
>> Ну вот стоим мы среди пустыни. Пробилось
колесо, на [музыка] самом деле. Баги
настолько хорошие, что мы спустя только
несколько километров поняли, сколько
машина стала сильно носить в поворотах
непослушная, но решили остановиться,
проверить и вот результат.
>> У нас сегодня [музыка] 38 температура.
Один из баги просто перегрел.
Остановились, сделали ему охлаждение,
так сказать. [музыка] Сейчас поедем
дальше.
>> [музыка]
>> В реальности жизни, чем больше мы
растём, тем меньше мы получаем
удовольствие. И это особо я заметил на
этом багетуре.
>> Во время становления мы, [музыка]
предприниматели, часто бессознательно
калечим себя. Потому что проходим
довольно-таки нелёгкий путь.
>> Перед приездом суда я был в режиме
напряжения, постоянно в режиме работы.
>> Последнее время казалось, что всё
немножко весь [музыка]
как-то бизнес. И вот всё, что происходит
в рабочей среде, немножко хаотично
происходит. Была какая-то растерянность.
Наверное, стоило уже приехать и
отвлечься.
>> Чем меньше сегодня у нас комфортных
моментов, тем круче я ощущаю жизнь. Даже
ночь в палатке, она реально дала те
эмоции, которые я не испытывал уже
совсем давно. заметил то, что пожарить
на палочке сегодня хлеб - это круче, чем
позавтракать в каком-то нереальном
ресторане. То есть, взвешивая [музыка]
одно с другим, ты реально ощущаешь вкус
этой жизни.
>> В своей деятельности и своей [музыка]
жизни я всегда стремился к тотальному
контролю. В этом туре я понял, что это
исходит [музыка] из страха, что вызывало
немало переживаний и сужало мою картинку
[музыка] внешнего мира. Каждый, кто
сегодня находится в состоянии вопросов,
возможно, сегодня наоборот тот день,
когда ты просыпаешься утром и заметил,
что ты замедлился, как-то что-то не
меняется, не хватает каких-то эмоций.
Друзья, это 100% нужно ехать на такие
туры.
Миллионы лет назад здесь простирался
[музыка] океан, и сегодня можно
наткнуться на останки его обитателей.
Найденные зубы принадлежат вымершим
акулам, [музыка]
жившим миллионы лет назад.
>> [музыка]
[музыка]
>> เ
Катаясь на баге по просторам, ты
понимаешь одно, как многое в мире ты мог
бы не увидеть. очень сильно понравилась
эта часть Казахстана, западная часть,
потому что я был на Алтае, я был в
центральном Казахстане. Настолько
удивительная природа. В этот раз я
узнал, что есть в Казахстане ещё и
пустыня даже. Вот очень был интересный
опыт. Мы прикоснулись к этой природе.
>> Каждый километр, который мы ехали по
этим дорогам на баге, я просто не
останавливаясь вправо-влево смотрел, и
на моём телефоне просто заканчивалась
память. Хотелось снимать каждый момент.
познакомился с очень интересными людьми.
>> У нас команда очень люди [музыка] все
разные. Самое первое то, что все здесь
собираются, потому что есть доверие
Орлану Колевичу.
>> Компания замечательная.
>> Первый раз в такой компании, чтобы так
много было людей, бизнесменов, мы все
стали здесь как одна семья.
>> Окружение меняет тебя. И, конечно,
находясь в таком окружении, которое
сегодня здесь в лагере, все общаются о
том, каким образом выстроить свою жизнь
так, чтоб ты рос, не имел стеклянного
потолка, но при этом ты не терял
качества кайфа жизнь.
>> Ты начинаешь ближе уже общаться,
формируется доверие некое семейные, тем
более у нас мужской клуб здесь так
получился.
>> Что мне понравилось - это общение с
людьми, у которых такие же ценности,
которые тоже двигаются какой-то огромной
цели. Люди, которые достигли успеха. И
ты понимаешь, во-первых, ты не самый
умный, во-вторых, ты не один. У людей
есть схожие цели, схожие проблемы, но
каждый двигается по-разному. Ты ощущаешь
себя в своей тарелке среди этих [музыка]
людей. Мне кажется, что это очень важно
для нас.
>> [музыка]
[музыка]
>> Сортус Байер - одно из самых масштабных
природных образований Мангастау. Его
белое салончиковое дно простирается на
десятки километров, а по корым
раскинулись [музыка] горы и равнины,
создавая впечатление древнего морского
дна, застывшего во времени. [музыка]
гроза.
>> Гигантская белая равнина, где небо
встречается с землёй. По краям горы и
плато, словно стены древнего мира. Здесь
природа говорит на [музыка] языке тишины
и пространства.
[музыка]
>> [музыка]
>> А
[музыка]
В Баге были моменты такие, как ты в езде
как будто в Нирване и состояние такое
эйфории. То есть, ну, здорово. Ну и
Казахстан, конечно, я увидел с другой
стороны, потому что красивые, большие
просторы, красивые горы, дикая природа.
Вы знаете, был такой момент, мы едем по
степи колонна Баги с двадцать
предпринимателями во главе с Маргуланом.
Смотрим, слева скачет табун лошадей. Над
нами порят орлы и бескрайняя степь. Ну,
если честно, моя душа как бы расстилась
по этой степи, освобождалась. Я
вспоминал себя, качества, которые, может
быть, где-то во время своего пути я
подзабыл. Это было очень круто. Природа
у нас в Казахстане шикарная. Я очень вот
[музыка] первый, когда Алтай посмотрел,
Центральный Казахстан посмотрел, теперь
Запад вижу. Я реально счастливый
человек, потому что одно из намерений
мое было увидеть Казахстан в полной
мере. сама поездка, сам багитур и
ощущение вот этого адреналина, пыли,
грязи и общения вообще в целом людьми из
разных направлений.
>> Есть и экстрим, и адреналин, и есть
комфорт, ребята. Это это вау. Каждой
багитур лучше и лучше, лучше.
>> Очень много пыли, очень много солнца.
Весь день потеем, спим в палатках без
интернета, без никаких коммуникаций.
Есть своего образа романтика в этом.
Техничка нужна. Техничка.
>> Да, Олег, слышу тебя хорошо. Я соверился
по
>> Я ожидал, что что-то натворю.
[музыка]
>> Поломка рычага на повороте не вписались.
И сейчас непонятно, то ли сел
аккумулятор, то ли бензонасос.
Приключение, полные штаны. Что?
Приезжайте, кому скучно.
Вот на баге номер два порвался ремень.
Будем менять. Сейчас поменяем буквально
5 минут и поедем дальше. Вон там трасса
и уже точка финиша. Недалеко.
Сделай.
>> Всё, 5 минут буквально заняло у нас
замена ремня вариатора. Сейчас садимся,
одеваем шлем и дальше.
>> [музыка]
[музыка]
>> Очень классное впечатление. Я в первый
раз нам баге именно долго еду, да,
такое, э, что определённый транс ты
получаешь, пока едешь. То есть есть
время с собой подумать. А вечером мы
смотрим YouTube в реальности Ргулан
Калича, который рассказывает, поэтому а
это наполняет смыслами. Потом ты до утра
не можешь уснуть, переваривая вот это
всё. В общем, я вам не советую сюда
приезжать.
Это очень жёстко повлияет на вашу жизнь.
Это 100% очень тяжело, а переварить уже.
Ощущение такое, что ты набираешься уже
там на год вперёд. Вот [музыка] с этим
совсем придётся разбираться, потому что
как жить иначе. Вот поэтому очень круто,
позитивно. Ну вот так вот. [музыка]
Вчера такая прямо шикарная ночь была.
Слабый ветерок, но он был такой
прохладненький. Место хорошее. Вот
локация уже в выбранном. Всё прямо
супер. Мне очень сильно нравится. Я
прямо в востоке. Многие ребята, когда
кого-то разбирали, нашли ответ на многие
свои темы.
>> У нас возникает особая атмосфера. Мы
слушаем, внемлим и стараемся черпать от
него его мудрость.
>> Один из глубочайших инсайтов, которых я
получил, мы с утра позавтракаем,
пообщаемся с Маргуланом Калиевичем,
пообщаемся с ребятами и потом 3-4 часа
едем в баги, не говоря ни о чём. Просто
пейзажа, природа и это медитация. здесь
в природе это совсем по-другому, да,
нежели когда ты смотришь YouTube
подкаст. Здесь всё располагает к тому,
чтобы поднять какие-то глубинные, да,
свои вопросы. Поэтому мне этот формат
очень нравится.
>> Слушать Маргунадана Калиевича, истории,
слушать его алгоритмы, а, энергии,
очень-очень важные такие моменты, потому
что в основном, что мы как бизнесмены
делаем? Мы говорим о бизнесе, мы говорим
о деньгах. А тут есть совсем другие
вопросы, философские вопросы,
психологические какие-то аргументы,
очень глубокие такие дискуссии. Поэтому
я был просто в в шоке о том, какая тут
информация. И, честно говоря, я был
зацеплён этим.
Баги. Ну, баги, наверное, это, в первую
очередь моё увлечение. Баги - это
скорость, это адреналин, это страсть,
это то, что заводит, наверное, мужчину и
рождает в нём детство. Маленького
пацана, который хочет пошать, наверное,
да, вернуться в детства, где не было
машины, где не было возможности
поуправлять. А будучи здесь взрослым, ты
можешь позволить взять себе эту машинку
и самореализовать себя как мужчину и
реализовать свой потенциал на баге.
Когда ты едешь на баге, ты просто
природа тишина. И когда ты едешь, ты
реально уходишь в медитацию, потому что
ты один. Ты потому что рядом даже если
человек сидит, ты его не слышишь, и ты
остаёшься сам с собой. И у тебя есть
очень много времени на размышление,
потому что ты понимаешь, ты всю свою
жизнь просматриваешь, это помогает тебе
внутри себя с самим собой поговорить.
>> Знаете, багитур - это что-то особенное.
Когда ты мчишь по степи, ты очень многие
вещи анализируешь, о чём-то думаешь, и
каждый поворот ты оцениваешь, как и
оцениваешь развитие своего бизнеса. Ты
мчишь 140, баг идёт великолепно, но
перед тобой закрытый поворот. Ты не
можешь понять, что там дальше, и тебе
нужно скинуть ход. Ведь риск бывает
оправданный, а бывает неоправданный. И
вот в случае с закрытым поворотом он
неоправданный. А бывает видишь поворот,
понимаешь, что можешь его красиво взять
и прямо в дуге заходишь и как ребёнок с
улыбкой мчишься дальше. Скорость
принятия решений, когда ты видишь
поворот, ямку и так далее, она такая же,
как и скорость принятия решений в
бизнесе.
[музыка]
Торыш долина шаров. Посреди пустыни
каменные шары, соотни, тысячи. Они лежат
как окаменелые планеты, рассыпанные по
поверхности древней Земли. Тарыш - это
место, где время потеряло счёт, а камень
хранит историю мира.
[музыка]
Подземная мечеть. Шакпак Ата - одно из
древнейших святилищ Мангастау. Её
высекли в миловых породах, укрыв в земле
от ветра и зноя. Когда-то сюда приходили
паломники искать ответы, молиться и
находить покой в тени каменных стен.
Сегодня это место продолжает хранить дух
тех, кто верил и оставил след своей
эпохи.
>> [музыка]
>> Пока Казахстанко огромный и наша планета
насколько [музыка] там прекрасная. Очень
большое удовольствие получаю. Никакий
там это техники нету, телефона нету. Это
классно. Как раз даёт возможность, чтобы
перезагрузиться и наслаждать нашей
природой.
>> [музыка]
>> Обязательно езжайте и помните, что через
баги, [музыка] через скорость, через
драйв вы точно сможете управлять лучше
своим бизнесом, своими ожиданиями, своим
опытом.
>> Двигаться по просторам Казахстана,
видеть прекрасные пейзажи, которые
запомнятся наверняка уже на всю жизнь.
>> [музыка]
[музыка]
>> Оглядываясь назад, точка отчёта, откуда
мы начинали, и смотря на сегодняшний
день, я думаю, что достигнут
план максимума, всё, чего я ожидал от
этого тура. Я возвращаюсь из этого тура
другим человеком. Абсолютно точно
понимаю, чего я хочу. И самое главное,
понимаю, как этого достичь.
>> 100% моя картина мира, она стала больше.
>> Я вижу более чистую [музыка] картину
цели, которой я двигаюсь. И я считаю,
что такой вид отдыха, он всегда нужен.
Он как бы перезаряжает батарею
допоминную. Я считаю, что это была
хорошая релаксация моей нервной системы.
Самое ценное, что было в этих турах -
это разговоры у костра. Когда кто-то
задавал свой вопрос, то каждый находил в
этом вопросе немножко себя. Когда я сюда
сейчас приехал за несколько дней, я
понял, что у меня запрос чуть-чуть уже
поменялся. Так случилось, что Маргулан
Колич я не успел задать вопросы, он уже
заранее на них ответил.
>> Любой ответ можно было так [музыка] или
иначе применить к себе. Я бы сказал, что
я получал ответы на все свои вопросы,
даже те, которые которые сам себе ещё не
задавал. Я очень доволен, что я позволил
себе [музыка] приехать сюда. Это того
стоит. Я записал себе сотню, может
больше всяких заметок, которые
постараюсь максимально быстро [музыка]
ввести в эксплуатацию.
[музыка]
Добрейшее, прекрасное утро на этом
рассвете. Переполнен эмоциями. Каждый
раз я вижу очень большие изменения.
Очень сильно с прошлого раза выросла
команда.
>> Большая команда. То есть, чтобы вы
понимали, а параллельно едет огромная
команда обеспечения. [музыка] Столько же
людей, сколько и мы.
>> Настолько невероятная организация, что
действительно можно ставить это в
пример. У меня, честно говоря, у самого
большое желание к такому уровню
организации стремиться. Да, [музыка]
>> и это очень круто. Это показывает, что
этот продукт он важен. И глачит туда
энергию свою. Вот [музыка] отдаёт.
>> У нас есть такая традиция. После каждого
баги тура
выстраивается стенка гостей,
выстраивается стенка команды, и мы
благодарим команду. Команда благодарит
гостей. 1 2три
>> Спасибо.
[аплодисменты]
>> Я еду домой полностью отдохнувшим. Готов
к новым вершинам, к новым победам.
>> Сегодня у нас последний день нашего
багитура, экспедиции. Всё было очень
круто. Перезагрузка у нас хорошая была,
да, когда будем возвращаться в родину,
конечно, будем применять навыки,
полученные здесь на баге Торы.
>> Ты вроде как раз хочешь [музыка] вот
этих инсайтов, какого-то понимания, а,
но как это, да, чтобы что-то было, для
этого надо что-то сделать. И вот поехать
на багитур - это одна из самых крутых,
наверное, вещей для меня. 10 из де. Ну,
опять вот надо создать [музыка] себе
условия, а дальше из этого максимум
получать.
>> Друзья, желаю каждому из вас расти
просто до небес, не иметь никаких
стеклянных потолков, но при этом иметь
те инструменты, которые будут давать вам
возможность получать [музыка] максимум
кайфа от этой жизни. Просто испить её,
собрать самую большую коллекцию ярких
эмоций, друзья. Больших скоростей,
мощных побед. Пусть всем сопутствует
удача. Топим вперёд. Обнял.
>> Тайны Устюрта несут в себе не только
величие [музыка] просторов и красот, а
дают глубокую пищу для сердца и разума.
Природа говорит языком [музыка]
вечности, а человек учится слышать
тишину. Пусть дарит нам возможность
стать ближе [музыка] к самому себе.
Одна из мудростей, которую я запомнил,
когда ты извлекаешь уроки из ошибок, то
они перестают быть ошибками.
>> Смысл Багитура в том, чтобы передать
людям, что истинные ценности - это не
про деньги. Истинные ценности - это про
жить счастливую жизнь.
>> [музыка]
[музыка]